back to layah inspired podcast powered by icon
plus so before we start i'm going to give you a
really quick news announcement so very excited
to share with you that icon 2.0 has launched
this is a power boost to the icon network for
next level decentralized finance and enterprise
adoption if you head over to my twitter page
there is a post of the interview that i did
with the founder minkim so you can check that
out later so that's really exciting for them but
without further ado we have a very interesting
guest today somebody who's very infamous
for blocking a ridiculous amount of people online
so i'm quite a fan of that and i think we have
a lot in common so joining me is of course
hotep jesus how are you doing i'm doing great
great great thank you for having me yeah it's
great to have you um i've been following you
for a while and i feel like we have quite a lot in
common in terms of politics crypto blocking people
online um but before we go into this i do want to
just sort of understand because a lot of people
don't know what hotep is um i told some people
that i was having hotep jesus on and they were
like oh i thought hotep was his first name so yeah
so that's the extent to which people don't know
about hotep so hello yeah uh hotep has become
sort of like a title uh like sir you know um
so uh hotep originally means peace or satisfaction
ancient metanator ancient egypt ancient egyptian
language um it's become a cultural thing for
uh what we call the conscious community uh
amongst the black community has a lot of roots
in the harlem new york here on the east coast um
but uh i represent hotep nation hotepnation.com if
you go to hotepnation.com hit the menu button and
navigate to the faq page you can actually find
out uh everything that we stand for get a lot
of questions sorted out and answered uh we uh
uh i think we have a lot of conservative values
so you'll see a lot of overlap with us and uh the
conservative right and some people will determine
and uh i think we just believe in um
independence we're not status by any means
um and uh all about like economics right
like you know what do you produce and then
um how do you exchange that with others and uh
what do you give in the world that's going to
nourish life essentially so kind of like
the good old expression don't ask what your
country can do for you but ask what you can
do for your country i don't know sort of like
personal responsibility a bit adding value on your
own without waiting that's pretty it's pretty it's
pretty close yeah yeah i hate to say that yeah
that's pretty close i wouldn't say identical
but yeah you're right in that lane right in that
vein yeah okay nice so this is interesting because
conservative values um and 2020 has been a crazy
year so a lot of things that i wanted to talk to
you today um about well firstly mainly you know
what's going on this week with cuties i know
you've got some opinions on that i want to chat to
you about blm um but let's start with cuties first
so this is interesting because actually i posted
um why is netflix normanizing and there's been a
lot of um backlash for that for some reason cuties
has become politicized right for some reason
pedophilia has become politicized um i know from
a lot of the things that i've read you're sort of
very much against what um you know netflix put
out in terms of duties but why do you think with
it's being politicized why do you think we're
sort of seeing towards the left we're seeing more
people sort of saying well actually it's supposed
to be for this it's supposed to be for that yeah
i've heard that argument um i couldn't stomach to
sit down and watch the film um even just from the
clips that i saw uh i couldn't stomach the film to
even try and imagine so there you know it's like
uh let's what i heard was they're trying to uh
shed light on the exploitation of children um
but in my interpretation they're doing that
by exploiting children i i don't i don't get
it like i think there's another way you know i
don't know what kind of weird [ __ ] they got
going on in france that would think this is cool
way to get across the message but i feel like uh
it's counterproductive it's counterintuitive
um to what they purport their purposes or
their mission is with the creation of
this film i think it's disgusting and um
you know as as a quote unquote hotep we have
studied the work of uh dr francis kress wilson
in her book the isis papers uh she predicted this
you know she predicted the normalization of the uh
lgbtq lifestyle which i have no problem with um
and uh i believe they deserve the right to marry
and uh the right to uh associate etc um and to
practice that lifestyle uh but uh my ancestors
like uh dr francis crush wilson has warned us that
the next stage of this uh would be uh pedophilia
and uh yeah go on sorry no no go ahead yeah i
mean i think it's really interesting because
when we talk about lgbtq or whatever you
know we sort of say yeah okay that you know
we agree they deserve the right to marriage and
so on and so on equal rights and everything but
why would pedophilia sort of be thrown into
that bracket why is that the next step for you
yeah well i couldn't answer that question directly
um because people might try to truncate the clip
and misconstrue my words but instead what i'll
do is i'll tell you a historical uh reference
and uh if we flash back to greece uh in
greece um homosexuality was uh normalized
as long as it was between uh an older man and
a young boy but if it was uh two men uh dylan
two grown men didlin then it was considered
homosexuality but otherwise it was considered
grooming so to speak i didn't know this yeah
uh i believe uh plato uh has um or socrates has
recorded some of these acts uh to which they
um i believe the author did not agree with
um and that's all i'm going to say about that
anybody can infer from that what they will
yeah i mean it kind of reminds me of um i mean
i know you said you're sort of not based on the
west coast of the states but it sort of
reminds me of like laws that we've seen
come out recently in california um sort of um i i
can't really i don't really know it fully follow
it but it's something like uh the laws have been
reduced if it's um the same sex and it's between
someone underage and over
overage or whatever it is
okay cool so you see the alignment yes i
guess i'm seeing some alignments absolutely um
but i mean it's interesting i've had people sort
of i totally agree with you when you say you know
if you want to raise the issue about exploitation
there's no need to exploit children in doing so i
was talking to somebody actually earlier today
about this um i don't know how much you know
about the uk or grooming gangs or whatever
but grooming gangs is a big issue in the uk
um grooming gangs what's that yeah okay cool
so you know about grooming gang so basically um
so just the facts of the matter is we have a big
issue so there's um it's the pakistani community
not obviously all of them there's a fraction um
it's a pocket of society um and they prey on white
poor um english girls um between the ages of i
don't know like 11 to 15 or whatever and they
groom them rape them and so on so that's been
a big issue in the uk now netflix and the bbc
actually did a documentary on this and they were
able to highlight the issue without wetting the
appetite of the groomers themselves essentially
that's what i'm getting at so i i to some extent
i appreciate okay fine so you wanted to shed
light on an issue but it's very odd that they
had to exploit children doing so yeah yeah such
a terrible decision to make i don't understand
uh what the people who signed off on this
were thinking yeah i mean either i mean you
keep here i mean i keep hearing things like
hollywood is full of all sorts so hollywood
um okay cool so another really interesting topic
this week is kanye west so he is kanye's doing
kanye he's uh going on the those rampage and
i think connie's an interesting one because he
often speaks his mind and sort of gets um trampled
on for doing so right he gets a lot of hate for
speaking his mind um i kind of wanted to get
your opinion and know where you're at with that
um you know he's a trump supporter he's not a
trump supporter um you know he's very anti this
whole victim mentality he's spoken a lot about
slavery and how people are enslaving themselves
just want to know where are you at with that do
you have any sympathy for kanye or are you uh
so um what good is it to have a free
body if you don't have a free mind
and that's where we are right now that's the
crossroads of the big political conversation is
um are you free to think as you wish uh
if you're not free to think as you wish
you you definitely can't speak as you wish um
so where we've we've uh reached a point where
uh people are committing thought crimes
and uh kanye is committing speech crimes
uh according to people who don't believe that we
should have free minds um so again i would like to
reiterate that we are in a position where we're
faced with mental slavery and that's what kanye is
is always alluding to is the fact that people
aren't free you know you make a certain
decision to say hey look i'm not supporting
a democratic candidate and all of a sudden
it's oh you're trying to throw the election right
like so i don't have the freedom of choice you're
saying if i don't make this decision then i must
be compromised or something must be wrong with me
right and that's the uh exact freedom that they're
trying to take away from us right now and uh joe
biden said uh if you don't vote for me you ain't
black hey um that's crazy and as as as as as as uh
uh inappropriate i should say as inappropriate
as that comment was from him it is actually quite
also accurate if we go by the numbers yeah by the
numbers if we went by the math that would be true
so in some ways i looked at him and i
said you scumbag for saying that but then
thinking objectively i'm like he's just cocky
and he knows exactly um the type of control
the democratic party has over the black nation
black people in america and i think that is uh
the the manifestation of the mental slavery
the fact that you can basically fear monger
people under saying vote or die right like so um
kanye's been going crazy on twitter recently uh
as people would say going crazy i would say
i think it's crazy and now i think he's uh
he's doing what you do when you get power right
yeah he got [ __ ] you money and when you get
that type of money um you start acting like
it um and and you start exposing some of the
things that are wrong with the world you know
like he was talking about the contracts that
record labels have i think it's a it's it's
it's time to you know i'm not a status i don't
believe that the government should get involved in
these contracts but i believe that we the people
um or industry who gets involved with these uh
record labels have a power to negotiate better
contracts we uh have negotiated better contracts
in the world of vcs the world of startups right
and those contracts have become quite fair
to both the investor and the uh startup uh
those contracts do not look anywhere near
the same as far as our label is concerned
and um the relationship is actually quite similar
where the artist is actually the startup but
has no equity in the thing that he started up
it doesn't even work like that in the startup
world usually you start off with equity and
people buy pieces of equity whereas when you
enter into a deal with these uh record labels
they start off with the equity and they tell
you what you're gonna get from your product or
your idea your startup so i think it's a fight
that needs to be had and i love that he's having
it um sam cook had that um fight they murdered him
um a lot of uh michael jackson had that fight
with sony are you on the mj one yeah and
we know what happened with uh the late great
mj um so and and kanye brought that up as well
but uh i've been following kanye i've never
uh deviated from uh being a a supporter of his
you know an advocate of his message i love kanye
i love what he does and um i think you just keep
doing it yeah i think that's cool i think
you know a lot of interesting things there
um let's go back to the biden comment right so
so you're not black if you don't vote democrat
i think biden is playing the ultimate game
of identity politics and you're right like
he totally knows that he's doing it and i think
it's very interesting to sort of hear you know
the democratic party being the party which will
say we will be your saviors um meanwhile sort of
not allowing you to have your own independent
thought um which in itself is to be honest the
most racist thing i've ever come across in
my life yeah yeah i i was uh thinking today
about this new premise called uh inclusivity is
actually masquerading as exclusive no exclusivity
is masquerading as inclusivity right yeah exactly
if you don't do it the right way yeah it's like
you know the left proposed to be inclusive right
and it's like inclusive of what your selection of
who you decide to include is actually exclusive
because you exclude an entire school of thought
because you don't agree with it so inclusivity is
actually exclusivity uh and it's rather disgusting
that they would uh try to play mind games with us
like this yeah i know i'm totally with you and i
think it kind of leads me on to the next thing
i want to sort of talk about which is victim
mentality and you talk about you know hoteps being
awake um you know uh i think that's the word you
used or you know kanye west is awake um people
sort of you know when the whole the riots the
blm rights were going on there was a lot of pain
on the streets um and rightly so you know rightly
so i can sort of i can feel the pain all the way
from the uk but my question to you then is why
aren't people why why are people sort of i guess
like you put it like kanye put it so i'm still
enslaved in their minds and unable to sort of wake
up um you know you talk about people having to
um lift themselves up from their own bootstraps
essentially yeah well the uh program was installed
in the the parents and the grandparents so
mentality yeah i mean human mind is a computer
and we very much have an operating system that's
given to us um from from the first time we start
interacting with people we start getting these
downloads from our mother our father and then
uh the greater environment and um people
aren't selected with what they allow their
mind to download and that's really what this is
about being selective in your downloads um people
are downloading a lot of propaganda people
are downloading a lot of misinformation uh
the um grade schools are the first places of
propaganda the liberal universities are the you
know uh the second level of propaganda as far as
education is concerned um thank you very much baby
what are you drinking uh a bit of coffee yeah um
so yeah you know um so so so you have that first
problem which is the parents are programmed right
i got lucky you know when i landed on this rock um
my father was quote unquote woke right he was
awake like real work or like like real work
yeah you know red peeled out so um i had
those seeds planted early you know so and
this kind of segues into the pull yourself up
by the bootstraps conversation right because
there's two sides of this coin
there's one is you can pull yourself
up by the bootstraps and the other one is uh
you don't even know how to find your bootstraps
no that is all right again um and and i think
that's that's the the bigger problem um we have to
show people how to find their bootstraps we gotta
you know yes they can pull them up but sometimes
we gotta turn the light on for them so they can
find their boots and get them on you know and
um so for example i was on a crypto
pod a couple weeks ago with shinobi
uh maybe a month ago shinobi and i was talking
about the advantage of being in proximity to
information has a lot to do with how fast
you excel in this world if you're in a hub
which is filled with a lot of information and
high net worth and networking individuals you're
going to rise the ranks of the classes a lot
faster than somebody who was uh born in a jungle
in the middle of south america right yeah right
the only thing they know is uh probably survival
right and then you can take that up next level you
got the kid in arkansas who you know uh lives on
a farm and he got chickens and they tend to their
own you know he'd be lucky if he has wi-fi right
now imagine somebody who you know their the
the the highest level of experience they
have with technology is wi-fi right like how
are you going to get them involved in crypto
how are you even going to start to explain krypto
to them and you know like but somebody who is
born in new york city who where some of these
digital ideas are abundant in just part of your
normal everyday life just especially like uh you
know taking uh public transportation how some of
these things have transactions happening digitally
it's just quite different than other rural areas
so yeah you can pull yourself by the bootstraps
but sometimes we need people to show other people
the way like hey you know like i like i spoke to
uh i've consulted quite a few people and i'm like
where do you live that's like sometimes one of
the first questions i asked where do you live it's
like all right well if you want to do that career
you need to get the hell up out of where you are
you know uh you might need to move to uh cali
or one of the major markets like uh texas
florida right if you want to excel and get you
know um more careers otherwise you need somebody
to show you how to do it online right and that's
why i think youtube is so great like you have your
platform wendy's platform where people can tap in
and get access to information i think that's what
makes this generation so different is that people
can just tap in and it's like they're getting all
the downloads from new york city by being in new
york city but they're still in arkansas getting
through their wi-fi i think these things are great
um but sometimes still you need that person to
retweet that onto your timeline right yeah or
run into it on instagram because you might be
let's say you're an instagram that
algorithm might just have you in a bubble
and you'll never yeah right so you get stuck in
these bubbles and and twitter is like that too
where you can get stuck in a bubble you only see a
certain type of message certain type of viewpoint
certain types of information and and and um so
that that that's like the second half the problem
can people pull themselves up by the bullet strap
well that's the first half of the problem now
can people pull this also out of bootstrap it's
the second half of the problem it's like well once
they have access to information now it's just
do you have the ambition and to want to go and
desire to go and do it and achieve what you want
to achieve right and i think that um black people
are in no position uh to complain uh about our
position in society because there are enough of us
who um are willing to help and and provide i
give a wealth of information out um to people
when i get my access to people uh and you know
carl civil right you know there's a lot of dope
dudes like it's a lot of people crypto blood you
know a lot of people who give great information
um and they're sort of pushed to the back
in favor of somebody who's going to complain
about white people right and and and kind
of keep the political circus uh going and um
yeah yeah that stuff that stuff is uh
sensationalized and you know yeah no i i
think you make some interesting points there
um especially about people being programmed
and you sort of saying well you're privileged
because you know your father was woke he sort
of instilled an idea into you that you know you
can do what you want despite the color of your
skin despite what people may tell you yeah um
but in terms of sort of showing like you said
showing people where their bootstraps are or
telling people that you do have bootstraps
okay so we have people online like you said um
that they can follow like yourself you have a lot
of successful black people which you know can sort
of show them that things are possible um but do
you think we need more because when i was you know
i'm here in the uk i saw what was going on during
the whole black lives matter thing you know the
riots on the streets and despite the negativity
that sort of comes with black lives matter that
aside there were people on the streets that were
in pain and they are unable to sort of see beyond
their circumstances so at what point can we sort
of instill something here do you think that we
need um i don't know do you think we need like
a martin luther king kind of energy going on there
like somebody that's going to come up and sort of
speak directly to black people and sort of say
like you know you can is it the education system
that needs to be changed um because honestly in
my opinion um no president is gonna do this no
black president you know you had obama you know
obama i don't really think instilled much faith
in the black community honestly um i know you've
got michelle obama which is supposed to be this
icon for black young girls but there's still an
issue there so how do you wake them up you don't
you don't you don't you don't um what we have
to understand is that um there is always going
to be the dumb deaf and blind see i come from the
school of authority the five percenters you know
and five percent is gonna be uh five percent
only five percent of nature is going to be um
righteous with their wokeness then you have the
other 15 you know who are are are awake but they
play the game like they grift and they're the
politicians and they know how this whole world
like joe biden like i'm straight up believing joe
biden knows he knows what he's doing he knows how
the democratic party are not helping your you
know your side like it's not helping exactly
but he's enriching himself right and his people
and his family right so then you have you know
so again we come down to this 80 20 rule right and
it's like 20 percent of people influence the other
80 percent right so 80 are dumb deaf and blind
now this thing is going to cross racial barriers
no matter where you go whatever nation you
have eighty percent of people are gonna
fall lockstep with uh the propaganda uh and of
course this is gonna vary based upon nations right
um and it's gonna vary especially to with
homogeneous places like china it's homogenous and
there's a lot of chinese pride that the chinese
people have and their heritage and they believe
in working together so it's going to be a little
bit different than a place like america which is
supposed to be so diverse in the melting pot but
80 of people gonna be dumb deaf and blind and that
crosses racial barriers i run into white people
all the time i'm just like oh you're just dumb
deaf and blind it's nothing i can do to really
help you um you know so what did the 5 nation do
well what we do is the people who um can see those
those who have eyes who can see ears who can hear
then we lend them a voice and we show them
the way we don't you can't force people yeah
we don't concern ourselves with people who uh
we have to force to conform it's actually a sin
to force people to conform to your ideas like if
you want to go out in the street and you want to
protest and you want to you know wear pronouns
who am i to tell you what you're doing is wrong
knock your [ __ ] self out i don't give a [ __
] right just leave me alone right so yeah what
i believe in is just making a message that just so
powerful that it drowns out these other messages
and i think that's what's more powerful you know
what is your message what do you what did you
build because it's not that you know black people
need to just need an alternative way of life they
need an alternative view they need somebody brave
enough that's going to step up and just show them
another way and when they see another
way and you see that other way is working
and they see the lambos and the ferraris
yeah they'll fall in line you know you see
the protests stop and say you know what i kind
of you know i think i want to be rich i think
i want to be one of the rich right and they start
seeing that it's okay to have luxury it's okay to
to live a good life uh socials do a good job
of making people hate being rich or hate the
rich and um they like to pray on the week um so
but you know let's talk about black lives matter
people on the street you know i think these people
uh have a legitimate right right like there is a
police problem in america i'm not gonna doubt
that there is a racial problem in america um
and i know they feel pain i know they feel pain
every time one of these incidents are blown up on
the media yeah right what they don't realize is
that their emotions are being tugged and pulled
you see there are a million problems with
the world there are a million problems with
the black community we can just start
with the top three top three are uh
diabetes high blood pressure and heart disease
i wasn't expecting those top three okay i wasn't
expecting that but yeah those are the top
three killers of the black community and
outside of abortion right nobody talks about
that nobody's marching in the streets for
that right a big mac gonna kill your ass
before a cop do right these are the facts
so who is telling you or who is selecting
the problems that you decide to fight here
i can't say who okay for my safety and yours
we'll cut off that which after yeah so you know
and it doesn't even matter who because we're
going to drown their message out we're going
to make them irrelevant you know um but uh who
who says police brutality is the problem because
i don't think police brutality is the first and
foremost problem i believe that there are problems
that you can solve that will solve that
uh just by being a tree being see police brutality
is is a branch of a bigger problem the biggest
symptom of the cause yes yes yes so the bigger
problem i would say is um inefficient economics
the economics within the black community is
broken therefore um they are left begging begging
democrats for health care begging democrats
for minimum wage or welfare or whatever it is
when really these problems like jason whitlock
was on my show last week and he said uh
nfl has produced more black male millionaires than
anything else i had to think about i'm like he's
absolutely right so where is this wealth going
when i believe over 60 percent of these athletes
are gonna lose that wolf by the time they retire
or a few years after they retire right so where is
this wealth going right so it's not like we don't
have the wealth we see rappers in the strip club
and they're throwing they might throw a million
dollars in a cert club in one night i've seen
a couple of times happen so it's not like the
wealth isn't there right it's just a matter of
what we do with it once we get it uh lauren hill
had this line she said it's not about what you cop
it's about what you keep so you can get money the
question is can you keep it right and then can you
multiply it um there there's not enough diversity
in in small business amongst the black community i
think that's a huge problem um we sent we tend to
center around the same types of businesses if you
take the top 10 um black um business directories
right they like to make these directories oh
check out all the black businesses all the
black businesses and they got the same fashion
hair entertainment right same thing over and over
again and even if these are lucrative industries
do not give me wrongs a lot of money and beauty
it's a multi-billion dollar industry in beauty
right the problem is we start competing with each
other instead of trying to find complementary
solutions within the business right so right now
like the eyelash thing is popping so everybody's
getting into aesthetics right and everybody's
doing aesthetics so it's like are we thinking
about the peripheral ideas that can happen to
uh facilitate some of these businesses right
and i don't think we're taking a look at that i
don't think we're taking a good strong look at
how we optimize some of these industries and and
become middlemen you know we don't control none of
the supply chain which is a whole nother story but
uh i'm gonna jump in um so a couple of things that
really very much about sort of understanding
really it's just business isn't it whether
it be financial financial literacy or um you
know learning how to sort of diversify within
the sort of things that the black community
offers when it comes to business but my question
is then um the black community right to use
this kind of term you know america is huge
it's huge you know there's all i don't know
how many black people there are in america i
can give you a stat maybe you know 40. it's very
much how many yeah yeah okay cool so 40 million
right so it's very the way i look at it it's very
difficult to sort of do you really think it's that
much of a community do you really think that
40 million people are that much you know black
people in the south the same as black people
on the east coast on the west coast like is
there really this kind of community whereby you
know there's um a conversation that can happen
amongst 40 million people which is guys you know
let's diversify our business let's do do you know
do you know what i mean or do you think or do you
think the problem should be tackled more at like
a national level put race aside and sort of say
you know people you know let's teach financial
literacy in school so that whites and black
people sort of understand financial literacy
you know when you make your million dollars know
how to invest that how to how to multiply it um
so once again once again we've fallen back upon
depending on the state yeah never do that that's
true but i'm just kind of like thinking we know
we don't when as as black people we do not want
to do anything nationally we don't want to
do anything in cooperation with other races
right um outside of economics i think when we're
talking about building the next generation that
is the responsibility of the elders of each
race or ethnicity right so grandma god teach
mama mama gotta teach daughter right so economics
do you think the kids that excel in finance learn
economics in school do you think it's in the
family oh absolutely not in school because they
don't teach it so it is in the family well that's
where the responsibility relies it relies on this
but like what you know what if you're just
born into that situation where you can't get
it from the family but then like it's like
we said you'd get it online and you'd look
right and that's why i said that's the big problem
having access to information like i said we got
option games right option gang's carl civil right
right he's showing people how to trade options one
of the dopest guys out here doing it black guy why
isn't he on the cover of black enterprise magazine
why that's that's my point you see what i'm
saying it's because he doesn't think like the
rest because he's because they've seen him in a
maga hat it's a problem but this is a black dude
from new york that is as real as you can get but
still make a proper difference yes and understands
wall street he's understands the streets and he
understands wall street right so a little too
real for them to to to push to the forefront and
that's the problem these people aren't getting
the looks that they should and the information
is not getting out there but you said can 40 i
think it's 47 million now the black community
is yeah so i think let's look at social media
do you realize like how much uh black people
have in common and is shown on social media
like some of these trending topics that come
from black twitter like black twitter could
easily uh on some days have like the top three
trending topics just based upon celebrity gossip
black twitter or black american twitter just
out of interest uh i would say black american
twitter which is black black twitter okay yeah
uh so you know some of this celebrity gossip
um can last you know conversations like
what was the conversation that just happened
uh recently i saw number one trending topic last
night um who was oh kanye right well kanye's
he kind of uh he took over twitter he penetrated
all sorts of twitter not just black twitter yeah
um who was the other guy i mean it happens all
the time right like uh odell beckham some little
groupie said something about odell beckham and
and and and black twitter had a ball with it
like there's a lot of different verses for
example the verses you ever see the verses
so verses they have like uh quote-unquote
battles so one of the battles they had was uh
uh snoop dogg versus dmx and they
come and they play like their top 20
hits or whatever uh they sell like 20 records
and they play them you never seen this before
i've never seen it maybe i have maybe i have i
don't know i don't know you show me after leave
me a link this is huge in the black community like
everybody who's black knows about this right and
that's why i said like you might be in a bubble
like you're in london you're in a bubble you
wouldn't you don't know anything about this stuff
right and this is what happens with social media
something can trend number one and you wouldn't
even know about it right because you're in london
and we're talking about american culture then you
have uh the last one they did was patti labelle
gladys knight right like like that's a classic
brandy verse monica was it was another classic
right do you familiar with brandy and monica it
might be a little too old i know of this but like
not obviously not as much as you are okay yeah you
have to show me after i we need to exchange some
links so yeah so you know they'll get a million
views on some of these things on on instagram
live a million view a live viewers a million
live viewers they're over indexing what people
would do on tv this is black culture so when you
have that many eyes that go to one single place
think about what advertisers would like to do
knowing they have a million live eyes focused in
on one spot that is also an opportunity for you to
plug your own propaganda to reprogram your people
so yes there's a community and they meet at
these places in these venues these digital venues
so there's a lot of opportunity to disseminate
the correct information i just don't think we
capture the opportunities but it is definitely
it is definitely a a community a lot of people
especially white people like to say oh there
is no such thing as a black community well
to white people it might not be but you know
when people say is there a difference between
a black man from chicago a black man
saint louis new york miami and houston
hell yeah it is how yeah it is without a question
there's definitely differences it's dialects
dress language all of that it's all different
you know um and in new york you whack and
in atlanta you green as [ __ ] they mean the
same thing right so there are differences
but there are points of unification within the
culture uh that we all meet up on a lot of them
might be um url rap battles you know but there
are places of unification and there are a lot of
unsaid gestures that we understand about each
other for example when we typed in child like
child please are you familiar with that talk
no i'm not no okay so so so you know when
you say child please that's very much southern
twenty i mean well we spell it like c-h-i-l-e
right oh okay but it's we're basically saying
cha yold please right we'll say child please
now it's spelled c-h-i-l-e and some girl grabs the
tick-tock and goes to tick-tock and she says chili
please so she doesn't even she's reading it but
she doesn't know where the spelling comes so as
i said we have like our own community that people
have no idea what's happening inside this bubble
so a lot of things can compos can be possible
um we just have to give people access to that
information and use these uh digital venues for
that yeah that's interesting to hear you know that
there is a place you know digitally which can
bring everybody together and it can be a good
place to sort of target and sort of wake people
up if that's you know what you want to do um but
i am conscious of time so i also kind of wanted to
chat to you um about crypto you mentioned lambos
earlier um so i don't fully know we chatted a
little bit earlier but you obviously you're you've
co-founded you're a partner of something to do a
crypto tell us coinbitsapp.com automatic bitcoin
investing you ain't got to think about it cause
a dollar per transaction uh wonderful app uh our
users are are are very happy um especially because
we go off the dollar cost averaging uh investment
strategy which is the smartest investment
strategy you can do across all asset classes
um so yeah it's great things happening over there
shout out to maher yusuf my partners who started
the company and brought me on later on as sort of
a branding and marketing art and uh we're just uh
slowly building that company up and um looking to
do some great things in the future with it yeah so
firstly how did you get into crypto and
what are your thoughts on bitcoin um i mean
being in tech you kind of have to know about
crypto right yeah so um you know i was in the
mobile app space for years and um keeping an eye
on crypto so i made a little bit of money when
they had the boom in 2017 you know and you know
i'm a traditional investor so i knew i knew to
get out at the top and so everybody else that got
hit i'm just like oh sorry for you i'm a trainer
traditional investor you know what you're doing
yeah but when i saw the crash i understood
something uh that was very important and i said
uh you know who who didn't lose money and uh
that answer was the exchanges yeah of course and
uh in my head i said you know i'd love to be in
exchange so um that actually manifested and here
i am working with my hearing yousef on that uh
bitcoin and trying to turn it into an exchange
some legal communist issues involved but uh
just some monetary hurdles will have to get over
yeah i hear you um but in terms of you know like
bitcoin being the next financial revolution i
mean what are your thoughts i mean i think it
was i think it was jason williams that tweeted
like the bitcoin is going to replace the dollar
or it's going to be you know america's main
currency is this even likely given that it can't
scale right now although people are building
on top of it you've got the lightning network
which hopefully sort of you know fixes this uh
a lot of people have um all right for example
uh the investor who comes in and invests at the
seed round right is very happy when the company
has a series a round because he's made money as
long as the valuation has increased in the company
uh and so on so forth so it it i hate to call it a
pyramid scheme but it oh damn but uh these people
are are pushing in my opinion um a pyramid scheme
you know um well you think bitcoin is a pyramid
scheme uh no i think that's what it is to these
people that push that type of rhetoric like
bitcoin is going to do all these great things
right i don't see bitcoin doing all these great
things um uh uh bitcoin is very interesting
the technology is very interesting i think
blockchain is a great piece of technology
i think there are many coins out there
that solve many different types of problems
um i love that it diversified money that's what
i love about crypto it diversified money and i
think that's what money needed it needed to
be diversified people needed other options
so i love crypto i don't want to just pile on
the bitcoin maximalist thing and say bitcoin
bitcoin bitcoin i think that's the wrong thing
to do um i think uh bitcoin is not a good uh
means of exchange but i do enjoy it as a store of
value and i think it can be used as a great store
of value and um i think that's what it should
be used for um at its current state obviously
yeah like there's the goat correct i don't see it
being used as money as we know it just physically
can't work the technology don't work it don't work
to do transactions i'm not waiting 30 minutes to
buy a cup of coffee it's just not gonna happen
and lightning network is just uh not the solution
um i think lightning network can work in small
communities like small trusted communities right
um so i think there is some viability for that
um but yeah you know these you know these these
these pumps of hope i just look at it this is
more propaganda marketing people trying to find
ways to boost their their ego trying to boost
their brand using bitcoin to boost their brand
making all these gestures of grandeur uh i don't
get involved in it much i don't respond to it much
it's just embellishment and i don't know i find
it childish i think it we should be honest and
tell people exactly what it is uh 60 of the
bitcoin mining power comes out of china i
don't call bitcoin bitcoin i call it china coin uh
interesting yeah that's what i call it yeah yeah
and bitcoin can't be for the people because the
people cannot afford the bitcoin mining machines
it's yeah i mean it's an interesting one
because there is that kind of bitcoin
maximalist rhetoric in the space and um i
mean a lot of people have sort of said that
that kind of claim that the mining pools
are centralized in china have been debunked
um which i think there needs to be more of an
explanation on that i don't think it's fully
been debunked in layman's terms um so i think
there needs to be more explanation on that but
um yeah i mean it's an inch it's an interesting
one um i think i hear you when people talk about
um you know crazy claims and i don't think it's
going to replace the dollar um i think something
will replace something will replace the dollar
i don't know whether it's going to be bitcoin um
but i definitely think that we are
moving forward in terms of there being
crypto cryptocurrencies being a the global
currency right so i think there will be a form
of digital money which will replace um the dollar
but i also think that we're gonna see a sort of
push and pull between whether so i don't
know how much i don't know how much
of crypto you know or whatever but you know you
have um cbdc's right so these are like central
banks digital currencies so i think we're
going to have a push and pull between that
and the people's cryptocurrency right which
is decentralized and it's for the people so i
think we're moving forward in that way but i don't
know who's going to win it's going to be a target
you don't think somebody has to win surely
there'll be a war between the people and
the government's coin no no they will
both coexist at the same exact time
interesting like positive and negative in
an atom they will balance each other out
that's what will happen there is no war between
the two coins one has one purpose and the other
one serves another completely different
purpose one is uh a machine to levy debt
upon people and the other one is a machine
to free debt from people so both will exist
oh it's interesting i i just i can't see them
coexisting when people find the power of crypto
even when you look at things like privacy
coins right like okay i'll show you an example
yeah go for it okay beautiful new house you
want to go into need to put a down payment
we only accept usd coin what are you going to
do about that i'm gonna have to have usd coin
boom done they're going to control at the higher
levels of banking if you go to amazon and amazon
does not accept your little rinky dinky coin
what are you gonna do are you just gonna stop
shopping at amazon you do you really think you're
going no of course not but that's what i'm saying
but that's what i'm saying so i'm saying so
then the government's coin wins no it doesn't
look like because i think i think i think what
we have now now it's sort of co-existing-ish
but only within a community right with only within
crypto i can't exactly go spend my crypto anywhere
or pay my rent in crypto i can't do that but what
does win mean when you say win win what how did
is it like becoming that win as in like becoming
that global currency you know there will be a
global currency it would not be the one for
the people though it will be the central bank
well then okay then that's what i'm saying so
then i would say people are are way too [ __ ] uh
to uh to fight the central bankers so the central
banks are going to win we can't even win the
the pedo war we can't even tell the left that
pedophilia is bad do you think we're going to win
uh a coin war do you really
think we're going to coin
that's what i'm saying though that that's what i'm
saying so i think one will win i'm not necessarily
saying that crypto will be outlawed i think
privacy coins are different um but i'm not
saying crypto be outlawed i'm just saying i think
one would win when it comes to being mass adopted
i think that the global establishment cryptocoin
will win will be a win for the independent coin
you see they need each other if the if the global
you know corrupt coin does not exist you don't
have a purpose for the other coins i hear you
i hate it they need each other they they they
really the even the crypto coins they
use when you say bitcoin oh what is the
talking point it's not how great bitcoin is
it's always in juxtaposition to the dollar
why can't you talk about bitcoin and remove
dot the dollar from the conversation completely
why can't you do that that's cool i like that
that's cool it's always the position to each other
so which tells me oh bitcoin must not be that
great if they can't just like the the the the
right the conservatives only thing they can
do is put things in juxtaposition to the left
what is your ideology what do you stand for how is
it great how is it going to benefit people don't
tell me about the left tell me what you have to
offer same thing with bitcoin don't tell me about
the dollar tell me what you have to offer you have
nothing to offer okay then leave me the hell alone
i can stack coins i can stack my satoshi's and i
can invest in it like gold and i can do well for
myself but don't sell me these dreams of grandeur
don't sell me these dreams of a global coin
because you can't even transact a cup of coffee
i don't want to hear about it i just don't want
to hear about it right no okay so but but they
don't need to win you see the bigger the global
crypt uh uh a corrupt coin gets the bigger
the let's call it the black market gets okay
it's they go they're gonna get it they they they
complement each other in a really perverse kind of
weird way i hear you i hear you i think that's
really interesting um but it's funny you know
you mentioned the right sort of talk about
what they can do um in relation to the left but
actually what i'll say on like a leaving notes we
are approaching an hour um for me joe biden is a
really interesting candidate because i don't even
know what he stands for other than he's not trump
like right right right that's his argument
right his argument is i'm not trump it's like
that's not an argument right you have nothing to
offer me right yeah other than high taxes yeah
and that's and that's the problem with the 80
the dumb deaf and blind are you allowing these
juxtaposition arguments to happen or you asking
these people no what do you really stand for
i hear you i hear you this has been a really
interesting conversation and it's been kind of fun
because it's kind of circled yeah background yeah
i want to thank you so much um it's been really
great chatting to you um i want to thank everyone
that tuned in um i think there's been a lot of
interesting comments i haven't really spoken about
that but uh yeah this is an interesting comment so
thank you so much i'm gonna end the broadcast and
uh we'll see you all next week thursday 12 est bye